never had an issue with beautiful I got
so many friends trying to convert me
into to reason like were you Christian
I'm Christian is it Born Again orn born
born again Christian yeah my wife is a
cath so so you believe in Jesus to be
God no no no no no there's a difference
I don't believe Jesus is my God we
follow him as a as you know as you
follow as a messenger that's how I
follow Jesus Christ as a messenger from
God okay I don't there's a lot of
Christians that it's a mixture people
would say oh Jesus Is God Jesus we need
no no no no no that's that's the son of
yes so different than other Christians
because there some Christians they say
it's God some of does say he's a Son of
God he's a messenger of God but even the
term Son of God what does it mean come
from the Son of God is it God his father
you know the term father was used by the
Israelites if you look to the Old
Testament Jacob is called the Son of God
Adam is called Son of God so Son of God
is not something which is like actual
father or actual son it means that if
someone is a righteous man like in
English language we say he a man of God
he's a man of God doesn't mean like
actual man of God he means someone who's
a p person upholds the laws of God
upholds so the Son of God mean is a
righteous man however the Romans when
they adopt Christianity they took
they said Jesus is liter Son of God and
that's that's blasphemy because God God
imagine I bring you a cow yeah and I
bring you a puppy dog and I say this
puppy this dog is is a child of the cow
say it doesn't make any sense God God is
no human being no God is there's not be
like God yeah no no I know what you
saying God is the creator we can't
there's not no of course you cannot
imagine God God is the creator of
everything so God creates us all we're
not children of God we are the servant
of God we are here to worship him so you
believe is more closer to Islam than the
Christianity than the many Christians
because yeah yeah no I get I get
because even about dying for example
about dying for sins yeah how Jesus
going to die for your sins when in the
Bible said everyone should be
responsible for their
sins that's a good question no no no
that's right you're right but I think
it's I don't know this is you know I'm
saying
you know you know what I'm doing brother
I'm not trying to speak about is very
very complicated I'm speaking about is
the foundation God gave us intellect
give you int intellect so he when God
told us about the truth the truth is so
clear you understand so I'm not speaking
to you about uh words in Greek and
Hebrew and no no no I'm showing you the
foundation the foundation doesn't make
any sense when you look at Islam Islam
is a simple clear religion goes in love
our there's only one God who is the god
of the creator of everything who sent
Prophet Moses Jesus Abraham Noah Jacob
Isaac ish Daniel Jeremiah the Jesus the
last prophet Muhammad came all of them
to teach us how to worship God that's it
but then God gave them something that
differentiate them from the rest of the
people for example Miracles Jesus used
to bring dead people to Life One the Mir
Prophet Muhammad did when his people
came to him and told him give us a
miracle he divide the moon into two okay
right okay like Moses divide the into
the seat into two yeah also they came
with the prophecies like one of the
prophecies that Prophet Muhammad
mentioned which is so powerful which we
can see right now he said that it will
come a time with interest you know
interest interest Banks and so on
interest will become widespread even if
you are not involved directly affect
you now if you open a bank account even
if you tell them listen I don't want
interest in my account they will still
use your money for interest of course
yeah so how a man that existed 1,400
years ago was able to prophesize about
something that we can observe right now
because he's a messenger of God and who
knows the future in details who knows
the future in details God so not if a
prophet comes and prophesies about the
future and he says a prophet of God I'll
give you another one you know in the
Quran you know about lgbtq people in
manchest
woman that is in the Quran not word for
words in the Quran Allah said that Satan
with inspire people to change Allah's
creation to change what Allah's creation
one of our schol ABD he died like 80
years ago he said meaning that we start
changing their own creation now people
are born healthy because they feel
something else they go change like woman
or a man the question you ask yourself
how this information in in the book that
came 1,400 years ago that's yeah I can't
get on to that topic that's it all the
cameras around no for the
cameras this man is a prophet of God
he's a prophet of God and there's many
prophecies in the Quran you know for
example one of the prophecies in the
Quran that Islam will overpower other
religions and we know the fastest
growing religion on the face of the
Earth what is
it what is Islam even though in the
Western World the mainstream media is
speaking bad about Islam but they don't
understand Islam this is what I see I'm
I'm never against any other religion I
don't whatever path you follow to go
that's your choice you're going to go up
there one way or another understand you
could be Jewish you could be Christian
you could be Catholic you could be
Muslim whatever you may follow we all go
to One path no I this is what I believe
I believe there different types of
following you know like I got a friend
of man he's b a Christian turn Muslim
right do you know what his main focus in
turning Muslim you know when you you
know helps the
mind started this is how he started that
just just to correct you and up learning
more just to correct you about the path
yes we do agree as a Muslims that if I
was alive at the time of Jesus the only
way to get to God Is by following Jesus
teaching before Jesus Moses before Moses
Abraham and so on now the last of his
Prophet Muhammad I don't believe that
all the religion I don't believe all the
religions will lead us to God you know
why because why this religion they don't
differ about branches they differ in in
fundamental teaching like Jesus Is God
or Son of God in the Quran says in the
Quran
says they say that the most beneficent
have a
son you came with the most horrible
statement and Allah goes on to say if
Allah allows the Heaven and the Earth to
show their feelings towards this evil
statement that Allah has a son then they
will the heavens will split
you understand so my point here is if it
was for everyone to follow their own way
to get to God what is the point of God
sending Jesus Moses Abraham I hear that
get that because God is the most wise
that's why God sent the prophets and
Messengers he sent the prophets and
Messengers to teach us
how that's it because why if if God left
left it up our feelings and our
intellect we have different feelings we
have different intellect you understand
that's why based upon his wisdom he
chose people and like I mentioned he
gave them prophecies and so on yeah no I
get that no I respect that that's why
you
know I you man that's good that's I
respect that
man but when you go home pray to the go
guide the
truth take I never C your name Michael
nice to meet you take
man